dans son bureau de la mairie de digoin
maxime castagna traite ses derniers
dossiers cadre quelques jours il ne sera
plus le premier magistrat de la ville
après 19 ans de vie politique il aspire
au repos tout en souhaitant passer le
flambeau à son premier adjoint fabien
genêt et ce dernier assume totalement le
bilan maxime castagna pendant trois
mandats
j'ai beaucoup appris à ses côtés je
crois que j'ai acquis un certain nombre
de compétences et d'expériences
d'expérience des situations d'expérience
de la vie de la commune et c'est une
expérience tout à fait importante et
indispensable indispensable pour
affronter les défis de demain
à 38 ans fabien jeunes ya donc une
solide expérience politique il fut même
conseiller régional venu de la droite
aujourd'hui il se présente sans
étiquette et met en avant une liste dite
de rassemblement d'ivoire mérite du
sérieux et de l'action parce que il ya
de gros enjeux devant nous la reconquête
démographique le développement
économique et l'emploi le soutien aux
familles et l'accès aux médecins et sur
tous ces points je crois que nous avons
commencé un certain nombre de
réalisations très importante que ce soit
les lotissements dans les quartiers mais
aussi le développement de la zone il
gerval ou bien sur le projet de maison
de santé qui est en cours de réalisation
qui est très attendu et donc je crois
qu'il faut poursuivre ses efforts pour
tous ensemble faire avancer notre ville
face à génération digoin se trouve une
seule liste envie d'agir à sa tête
philomène baccot elle a réussi à faire
l'union de la gauche
mais cette socialiste présente elle
aussi une liste sans référence affiché
aux partis politiques et son truc pour
la campagne c'est de faire du porte à
porte
j'en fais beaucoup je pense que les
municipales c'est sont une élection de
proximité c'est on vote pour une
personne qu'on connaît qu'on a vu moi je
l'espère moi c'est ma façon de procéder
voilà on est venu vous voir je voulais
vous donner mon document auprès lors des
dernières élections cantonales
elle s'était imposée face à un certain
fabien genêt ainsi cette jeune
conseillère générale met en avant son
actuel mandat il son travail dans
l'opposition municipale pour faire
basculer digoin et elle a peaufiné son
programme déjà assainir la situation
financière et stopper l'augmentation
incessante des impôts et des taxes qui
pèsent lourdement sur les digoinais je
veux développer l'offre de formation
soutenir les plus fragiles en créant le
transport à la demande et le
développement du ccas je veux donner la
parole aux iguanes est en créant des
instances de démocratie participative à
forum des associations et aux déplacés
peut-être la maison de santé avec
seulement deux listes l'élection
municipale à digoin va se jouer au
premier tour
et comme rien n'est joué d'avancé la
campagne va se dérouler jusqu'au dernier
moment